tras llegar a Panamá procedente de la
selva del Darién los migrantes
permanecen en los puestos de recepción
migratoria cercano a la zona fronteriza
con Colombia luego se les permite
avanzar y continuar el trayecto rumbo al
norte del continente este recorrido lo
hacen los migrantes en buses que parten
desde Darién y hacen una parada en un
albergue que tiene el gobierno panameño
en la provincia de chiriquí fronteriza
con Costa Rica es en uno de estos
vehículos donde ocurre el accidente que
deja sin vida a varios migrantes el
presidente de la república de Panamá
laurentino cortizo dijo a través de sus
redes sociales que lamentaba el hecho e
informó que las autoridades trabajan en
el lugar para el levantamiento de los
cadáveres la atención a los heridos y
conocer las causas de este accidente por
otro lado también las autoridades
panameñas se han informado que en lo que
va del año 2023 más de 37 mil personas
han atravesado la selva del Darién la
mayoría haitianos más de 14.000
Ecuatorianos o más de nueve mil y
venezolanos más de 5000